diese schweine leben nur um später
gegessen zu werden aber bis es soweit
ist soll es ihnen gut gehen
solches die linse schmutzig aber so ein
bisschen ist es ja schon auch utopia
hier jetzt natürlich aber warum nicht
98 prozent der schweine in deutschland
leben anders sie stehen in
konventionellen stellen
da geht es um masse und um effizienz
eine sache die wir alle wissen aber
gerne verdrängen
ich weiß natürlich dass diese halb art
der haltung weit weg von der von dem was
natürlich ist das wie ein schwein und
ich sage aber nicht dass es schlecht ist
ich war aber alles was sie brauchen der
eine hat etwa 4000 schweine der andere
knapp 50 es sind zwei welten und wir
verlassen jetzt utopia wieder und
schauen uns heute mal die konventionelle
mast an
denn seitdem corona ausbruch bei
turniers diskutiert deutschland über
fleisch mal wieder
[Musik]
florian hollmann ist 28 jahre alt und
konventioneller schweinehalter der messe
knapp 4000 schweine
er nimmt es mit dem handy mit in den
stall und zeigt uns wie es sein team
geht
vor einem jahr hatte den hof übernommen
und mästet schweine konventionell aber
mit der freiwilligen initiative tirol
das heißt seine schweine haben unter
anderem 20 prozent mehr platz als
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben etwas um sich
zu kratzen beschäftigungsmaterial und
eine kühlung
sie stehen aber ohne strom auf den
guitar böden und haben kein außengehege
80 kilo
sein hof war von der schließung bei
tonis direkt betroffen hunderte
schlachtreife tiere wurden nicht wie
geplant abgeholt um schwein lebt ja auch
von der bezahlung bis letztlich richtig
geschlachtet werde ein jahr und diese
vorlaufzeit die habe ich wenn ich zum
prozess in gang gesetzt habt das ist
dass die sau gesamt habe die ferkel
geboren werden und system ernährt habe
dauert halt ein jahr und das kann nicht
schlecht voraussehen das ist eigentlich
das problematik die wir im moment haben
dass wir eben nicht einfach den
prozessen der fabrik die autos herstellt
für zwei drei wochen pausieren können
weil wir sagen ja es ist jetzt nicht so
viel abgenommen
wir sind in dieser produktion drin dass
wir angefangen haben müssen ja der auch
seinen eine hochspezialisierte just in
time produktion wie auch auf diesem hof
das einen monat lang nicht geschlachtet
wurde sorgte für staub im stall
es kamen neue ferkeln aber die alten
waren noch nicht weg rund 400.000 tiere
standen in der warteschlange
für uns als als tierhalter ist das
deswegen rückkehr weil unser schwein ist
schwer werden wollen als verbraucher
immer ein schnitzel haben was gleich
groß ist und dafür brauche ich auch
immer ein schwein was gleich schwer ist
im durchschnitt ist jede und jeder
deutsche etwa 60 kilogramm fleisch pro
jahr 2009 10 wurden in deutschland 760
millionen tiere geschlachtet
davon waren 55,1 millionen schweine
geschlachtet im hauptwerk pro tag
zwischen 20 und 30 tausend tiere die
großen schlachthöfe haben genaue
größenvorgaben und wollen einen
bestimmten fettgehalt zu große und zu
fette schweine sind weniger wert
bei dieser ganzen geschichte haben wir
200 euro bekommen
dazu kommt dass ich das bei noch ein
bisschen länger wirklich halligalli im
stall wenn die meist zufällig bekommen
das ist kein witz also wenn du dir auf
den 6 das werde ich immer wieder gefragt
und gibt ihn noch nichts doch wachsen ja
und ich habe sie den bits wird dann
gibt's auch was was zu dir in der
diskussion von den verbrauchern und
verbraucherin wünscht mehr ehrlichkeit
also im einkaufsverhalten nicht nur der
wunsch vor der laden also vom supermarkt
nach mehr tv sondern auch an der kasse
halt dass es eben umgesetzt wird im
moment sehe ich einfach noch dass der
verbraucher halt viel günstiges fleisch
essen möchte kaufen will
für die leute produziere ich bin froh um
jeden der eb wertschätzung bringt und
auch teures fleisch kauft ich bin
überhaupt nicht böse und ich sehe das
auch nicht geben wir als persönliche
kritik an oder so stellt einfach nur
fest dass der verbraucher so tickt und
anscheinend an der theke entscheidet das
system finden wir gut und das obwohl den
meisten menschen klar ist das system ist
schlecht für tiere menschen und umwelt
regelmäßig gibt es schlimme berichte und
bilder aus allen teilen der produktion
turniers ist ein beispiel ein anderes
sind solche zahlen jedes jahr schaffen
ist 13 millionen schweine nicht mehr zum
schlachthof sondern landen im müll
der druck in der branche ist groß seit
2010 hat ein drittel der schweinehalter
aufgehört in immer weniger stellen
stehen immer mehr tiere
ich frage mich halt auch oft so in der
ganzen diskussion darüber wie werden
schweine gehalten wie ist es in der
industriellen produktion und so würde
ich das dann machen wollen dass warum
bin ich landwirt das macht ultra viel
spaß das ist die vielseitigkeit der
umgang mit den tieren das gibt einen
richtig viel zurück klar der druck ist
hoch und der druck wächst und er steigt
ich habe mich freiwillig dazu
entschieden ich bin seit einem jahr in
betrieb
mein vater hat den betrieb von seinem
vater übernommen hat ihn entwickelt so
wie es halt in der zwei typisch war was
was eben erfolgversprechend war ich
fange gerade an
ja wer weiß was sich in zehn jahren
darüber sage überleg mal dein erstes
jahr als angefangen hat war die korona
krise guck mal wie wir da die schweine
gehalten haben wie machen wir es heute
einige initiativen und höfe setzen
bereits auf mehr tirol mit auslauf und
strom mehr geld gibt es dafür aber oft
nicht für florian hollmann kommt es
deshalb nicht in frage
der ehemalige sternekoch franz keller
hat dafür wenig verständnis und fordert
einen radikalen wandel deshalb muss man
die gesetzlichen vorgaben so machen dass
man sich das auch dass sich der bauer
das leisten kann nun die bauern machen
alles mit wenn sie geld verdienen können
aber wenn man ihn halt die möglichkeit
gibt auch mit schlechter qualität geld
zu verdienen dann tun sie das auch also
einfach zu ihm und zu seinen bunten
schwein kehren wir in unserem nächsten
film zurück
[Musik]
damit ihr keine folge mehr verpasst
vergesst nicht unser kanal zu abonnieren
und hier kommt ihr zu unserer playlist